[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez tout de suite on va voir qui sera
la meilleure madonna c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le candidat enora malagré c'est du show
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vois que les gars sont ceux des
garçons sont assez l'oeil ah oui elles
vont pouvoir continuer parce qu'on m'a
donnée maintenant
vous allez voir madonna voilà c'est la
deuxième candidate et là vous allez
prendre beaucoup de plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
énorme et suivra
est-ce qu'on peut gagner un petit matin
on trouve vraiment non mais c'est vrai
vraiment comme neuf pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ça
cet élan
[Musique]